The joe rogan experience.
A lot of experts out
there talking about stuff.
That's why a fight like next weekend is
so fascinating because between Tony and
could be, nobody knows what
the fuck is going to happen.
It's one of those fights where
everybody's like, damn, I don't know.
And you got all these people breaking
it down on one side and then you've got
people making compelling arguments on
the other side and you're like, okay,
this one's going to be weird.
I've been,
I've been bouncing back and forth
between my pick for that fight. But um,
I guess because I've been
bouncing back and forth,
this isn't necessarily where I'm
going to stay, but I feel like, okay,
I don't see how that can change.
But again, like you said,
there are people that are making these
arguments and if somebody convinces me of
something that kind of defeats
this argument, then it's like, man,
now you opened the door for this again.
And what I think is like when I first,
my first thought was,
could be with this guy.
He takes everybody down and he
controls you and beat you up. Right?
And you think he's going to do that?
And then, um, but Tony is this guy,
he just does not, he's like one of the
submission first kind of guys. You know,
that argument submission.
Our position told me he wasn't even
too worried about the position.
He'll create scrambles.
He's,
he's aware of where he is at all
times and what he's giving up.
So I feel like he would
just continue to scramble.
He'd be able to get back
to his feet at least. Um,
and then I go back to Khabib and seeing
Tony Against Kevin Lee and Kevin Lee
kind of control them early in that fight.
You know,
he was able to pass his guard and do some,
some good controlling things.
Now if a guy like could be,
you can do that right then he's
not getting back up and could be,
he was going to be able to take him now
and he is the best wrestler in the game.
Like without a doubt. Yeah. Good
arguments. Good arguments. You know,
I think another argument is it Kevin,
when Kevin Lee fought Tony,
I think everybody knew Kevin
on the staph infection. I knew.
I saw him walking to the cage. I look
at his chest. I was like, Holy Shit,
that guy's got staff.
I knew it was going to be weak.
I knew in compared to the Kevin Lee,
the destroyer that you see when he's
on point and in shape, I was like,
this guy is going to be compromised.
Yeah,
and he's also a big one 55
so it's a hard cut for him.
Whereas Tony makes it mean Tony can get
pretty heavy, but he's super disciplined.
He makes it easy. His endurance,
his endurance is off the charts,
off the charts impeccable.
He was posting the other day that he
went on a six six mile run at one o'clock
in the morning. It's like extra credit.
He wrote Hashtag extra credit. I mean,
he's an animal.
I mean Eddie Bravo trains with them
up there in big bear all the time.
He said he's never seen anything like it.
So to do is just everybody else like pace
and everybody up the hill coming back
down. They're still trying to make it up
the first time he's running past them.
The second time he's a fucking
animal. Like aw, he wants it bad.
But so he knew that Kevin going
into that fight was compromised.
So if he knew Kevin was compromised,
maybe he decided to just let them work.
Let them work that first round.
And Kevin's don't know joke.
Kevin's fucking dangerous. Very
skilled. Very skilled, very aggressive.
Very strong. Very dangerous.
You know. So Tony,
he got in bad positions in fight though.
Did you get mounted in the first round?
He is guy got passed. Pretty convinced.
Like pretty easily early in the fight.
Um, but that's crazy because if, if he,
if he did take that time off even
knowing that a guy like Kevin Lee was,
you know,
compromised.
That's still a high level guy to be,
I'm going to take this time off.
It'll be a little bit laxed. Might
just have been Kevin. Is that good?
I really wish that fight took
place with Kevin Healthy.
Really wish that fight
took place with Kit Kat.
I think Kevin is an interesting
guy because he's, he
talks a lot of shit. Yeah,
he's really aggressive. He fights well.
He looks the part, when you look at him,
he's fucking jacked. You know, that's
a bad break for a dude like that.
He had like a golf ball growing out of
his tit. Yeah. That was crazy. I mean,
it could happen again relatively soon
depending on how this fight with,
with Barboza goes. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's an interesting fight for Barboza
to Barboza has got to recover from that.
Mauling the can you put on them?
That was horrendous. But you know,
I'm an opponent Tony. Yeah,
exactly. And I want to look back at,
um, the bibles to fight, but
when I, when I did look at it,
he defended, he defended some of those
takedowns early, you know what I mean?
It's against cubby now.
Yes. You can defend,
you're going to be the strongest
in the first round, but still, um,
there's not a lot of people defending
it could be his takedowns no. You know,
there's a great New York Times
article that was us just on, um,
like three or four days ago about
wrestlers from Dagestan. Yeah.
And about how wrestling is their way out
because so many of them trying to prove
themselves, they wind up joining
those Islamic terrorist groups and uh,
that these coaches try to take these
young aggressive kids and give them
something, something else and give
them another alternative, really,
really well written article.
Interesting stuff about like how powerful
these guys are and how young they get
him into it. And when you see
Khabib, the thing about him,
it's like he's not doing different
things than everybody else.
You know what I mean?
Like some people are doing different
things like wonder is doing different
things. Like he stands totally
sideways, his hands are down,
he's thrown front leg sidekicks,
he's doing a lot of different things
and you're like, oh, okay, this is some,
a new thing to adjust to
Khabib's doing standard shit.
But he's just doing it at not just a
notch but several notches past what
everybody else is doing. I think that's
the thing about these Dagestani guys. Um,
it's crazy because like this American
wrestling style folkstyle wrestling of
being on top and having that control,
that's a big deal. But like Nick Lens,
that's one of his strengths. Like when
nick gets on top of you, it's like a,
the Dorf, you know, like
he's not going anywhere,
but he can also escape that. A lot of
guys, same thing with Mike Brown, but um,
Nick Lance got written out at the w in,
in the fight in Brooklyn.
I forget which car that I'm
Holly Holmes and Jermaine demand.
You know that car he wanted by getting
right. No one's lost one, which fight,
I forget who, who he fought, I
forget he fought a Dagestani guy. Oh,
he just got written out against his
own style. That's what I'm saying.
These guys are better at what
they're with the American style is.
But like for something like that,
I want to see one of those guys against
a guy like Greg Gillespie, you know,
cause that style of wrestling of being on
top and grinding on you, that's a high,
like a high level wrestler like
that no fault at four time.
All American national champion kind of
guy with that kind of conditioning who's
not going to break. I want to
see that battle. That's like,
cause that'll be like a,
a national championship with two
guys that can punch and kick a bit.
Well look at garlic, Jordan Burroughs or
Jordan Burroughs getting into MMA. Yeah.
Like what happens when he fights when
those Dagestani guys. Yeah, exactly.
But see there's Dagestani guys
and then there's could beep.
He's another notch above them.
He's a notch above them.
Like there's a lot of those guys that are
real good. They're real tough, you know.
But he's another level.
He is a scary level.
I when you see him on top of guys like,
like especially the Michael Johnson,
that was helpless. That was
mauling man, horrifying.
And having a conversation with him,
pleading with him to give up.
You must quit title shot.
My title shot. They deserve,
just keeps it and he's got
his arm tied behind his back.
He's punched him in the face. It's
horrific. Yeah, it's horrific.
I mean he can do shit to you that like,
it's like white belt,
black belt beat up against the best guy.
That world. The best guys in the world.
Michael Johnson.
Michael Johnson clipped him now.
But here's the thing about that fight.
It's interesting to me.
Could beep came into that
fight with the same problem.
He went into the Tony Ferguson
fight that was canceled.
He cut too much weight in his liver,
apparently shutdown making
wait for that fight.
So then they went into the next fight.
Um, and he didn't make weight at all,
rushed to the hospital. Then he hires a
nutritionist. Looks fucking fantastic.
Had been against Barboza,
has zero problems making weight
now he's got it all under control.
But you got to wonder if he was
compromised in the Michael Johnson fight.
How much of a factor did that play? Is
the him getting stunned? Yeah, he got,
he got clipped.
You got clipped and you know as well as
anybody that when you're dehydrated or
you have been dehydrated, you just
don't take a punch as well. Yeah, yeah.
Dehydration, conditioning,
those things. You know,
those things help you recover when you,
when you're hydrated,
your conditioning is, is up to
par. Um, yeah. I don't know. He,
you seen him take some punches.
He always backs guys up.
He's always coming forward and he does
eat a lot of shots coming forward.
But you know,
if his conditioning is fine,
and that's the only time that I can
remember him getting hurt in a fight from
taking shots. Like the same thing about
both of Barbosa was throwing at him hard,
hard, you know, specially Bali.
Yeah, just stuff. Everything.
Cause he's like a Zombie.
He got wheel kicked a couple of times.
Nothing club in the back of the head
would wheel kicks. Nope. Sorry. Not Today.
Just constantly charging forward, man.
He's a fucking tank. Terrifying guy.
But this is the fight.
To me that's the most intriguing.
Other than him fighting Conor,
him fighting Conor for the name value
is like chaos, right? Like Holy Shit.
Like they might do that. If he
wins, they might do that. Do that.
Russia ood if they do that in Russia,
Connor better bring his own food.
I tell you that. Hey, better
bring some fucking corn,
beef and cabbage right from
the motherland. You don't
want to take any chances.
But when Khabib,
um,
when Khabib's fighting, Tony, the thing
about Tony is that Tony so creative,
like he's very unpredictable.
You don't know what he might step in and
throw an upward elbow. You know, he, he,
he'll do all kinds of weird shit.
He'll do Granby rolls on you.
He'll die for a leg. You know,
he might try to take Khabib down.
Who knows what he's going to do and
stand up. He's got legit knockout power,
legit and he can take a shot. Rolls
with punches real well, doesn't mind.
When he gets hit hard,
he just kind of rolls with Shit,
comes back like the Barboza fight.
The Barboza fight with him was a
very interesting fight. Yeah. That,
that fight was fun to watch.
Like I can't,
I can't remember all the details
right now, but I remember thinking,
I remember tweeting, man,
I'm watching this and these
guys are savages. I, I can't,
I can't believe I thought one of these
days I have that daddy can steal.
It was like, man, I fought them both.
But yeah, that fight was
fun to watch. And that's,
that's that common opponent thing
that you say and I don't know.
It's one of those things also though,
because you know the rule fighter ABC,
that thing is a play on like stout beats,
like stat Jeremy Stevens beats down.
I'd be Jeremy and Jeremy Stout beats me.
It's this crazy,
crazy thing where it just doesn't add up.
It doesn't add up MMA.
Math just doesn't work.
Okay.